[Music]
when life gets us down we play our
guitar okay not us but Ernesto dela Cruz
does Coco was one of the most beautiful
Disney movies of 2017 and we bet many of
you have watched it more than once but
have you ever found Nemo because we have
do you want to be a DIY expert check out
our friends at crafty hackers they have
the best hacks crafts and everything DIY
watch their videos for the best
household tricks DIY decor and fun
recipes if you love making crafts for
your friends or just trying new things
they have everything you're looking for
be sure to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any awesome hacks and crafts
Pizza planets have you noticed that the
Pizza Planet truck has consistently
appeared in every single Pixar movie
except for the Incredibles
it's a Toy Story reference that seemed
to have carried on and we don't even
know why but the Pizza Planet truck is
actually awesome in the beginning of the
movie you can see miguel open a window
and a truck zooms right past him if you
pause at the right time you'll see
Pixar's biggest Easter egg ever we're
not talking about an actual easter egg
we're talking about the famous pizza
planet delivery truck although you can't
see it in this movie the truck has a
sticker that says Kratt FM which is a
shout-out to Tia Crowder one of Pixar's
employees you could also hear the truck
play heavy rock music for the majority
of the time although we're not sure if
that's in any shape or form connected to
anything else
we're glad this Mystery Machine returns
for another Pixar adventure The
Incredibles
but since The Incredibles the movie
didn't have Pizza Planet in their movie
Coco decided to give a little shout out
to them too
unless you pay a lot of attention to the
background this scene can be easily
missed because let's be honest
watching Miguel and Hector go around
town was just far too more entertaining
to focus on anything else but The
Incredibles shout-out was actually very
visible especially since pretty much
everyone has seen the red posters and
know what they look like you can see the
Incredibles poster when Miguel and
Hector walked through the land of the
dead it's on the right side when they go
right through the slightly creepy
skeletons but why would the land of the
dead even have the Incredibles as an
advertisement does the land of the dead
get movie releases way later than
anyone else will probably never know the
answer but if it's true they're in for a
treat because there have been a lot of
awesome movies that were released after
The Incredibles
speaking of with the residents of the
land of the dead gets scared of horror
movies okay too many questions let's
move on to the next little easter egg
you don't know unless you know
everything about Pixar a113 the pizza
planet isn't the only continuous
connection you can find and Pixar movies
it seems like the Pixar staff are a
tight-knit community that appreciates
where they came from and how they got
their jobs the room number a 113 is
something you never pay attention to but
it's something you can often find on
various classrooms license plate numbers
and so on in various Pixar movies it
represents the classroom that was used
by character animation students at the
California Institute of the Arts many of
the students were a part of the Pixar
staff so the tribute to the classroom
can be seen in plenty of cartoons you
can also catch it on the decor of the
Bureau of family grievances in Cocoa
just pay close attention to the door
behind the Riviera family so next time
you watch a Pixar movie see if you can
spot the room number we can guarantee it
it's in a way more movies than you know
and to be completely honest the story is
pretty awesome and deserves to be its
own movie we'd love to know more about
what it takes to be a Pixar animator
because judging from some of the facts
we found it's a really hard job so shout
out to the animators from classroom a
113 who managed to make it big in
Hollywood Toy Story okay two more Easter
eggs before we move on to some of the
more interesting facts and trivia about
this amazing movie Easter eggs are the
coolest things and we love finding
connections to the different movies and
creative shoutouts they make to each
other Coco is exactly the same when it
comes to shoutouts you can catch another
shout out to toy story with the skull
have you noticed it if you're not a big
Toy Story fan this one might not make
sense so we'll try to break it down
do you remember Sid's famous skull
shirts it's what a lot of kids wanted
the skull shirt has been remodeled in
Cocoa although you can't spot it in the
movie the promo posters actually have
the skull that's been revamped as the
day of the dead sugar skull this type of
skull is very well-known in Mexican
culture as the Day of the Dead is
probably
one of the most interesting cultural
holidays ever it's all about honoring
the deceased loved ones and people
believe that the gates of heaven open at
midnight on October 31st and the spirits
of children that are no longer alive can
be reunited with the families
it seems very fitting that Sid's skull
shirt got a makeover that actually
represents a culture The Shining but
since KOCO actually has a pretty scary
story if you're not a fan of things that
aren't alive you probably guessed it
also has some references to other scary
movies like The Shining which is easily
one of these scariest horror books ever
KOCO gave a shout out to Stephen King in
one of the early parts of the movie and
it was confirmed right the director
himself you can see the axe from The
Shining stuck in a tree stump in a scene
where Dante wakes up and climbs the tree
where Miguel is it's hardly noticeable
but a pretty impressive shout out in the
very same scene there's another
reference to the shining it's the Redrum
and it's located right next to the axe
if you don't know what the Redrum means
just spell it backwards and you'll
probably understand why the shining is
actually a horror movie some of you are
probably way too young to know about the
Redrum scene and the shining in general
so it's very interesting that such
obscure references would make its way
into a movie like Coco we definitely
didn't expect to see such dark Easter
eggs in here but it looks like the
director was a huge fan of The Shining
genuine shoemaking the riviera family
shoe making facilities were actually
inspired by a real shoemaker shop in
mexico if you ever visited one you know
that they're extremely detailed but also
slightly unusual looking and definitely
not what any regular shop would look
like you probably also know that when
you interest shoemaking business you're
always hit with the smell of leather so
the team behind the movie made sure they
included a lot of details that made the
store look as alive as possible this
also meant adding defunct tissue making
tools rolls of leather and things like
old signs this all made it feel like the
Riviera shoemaking business was actually
around for hundreds of years which
really made this story even more
important and heartfelt we're sure the
movie would turn out just fine if it
didn't have the same kind of details but
let's be honest it's tiny details like
these that really make us appreciate
good movies and we bet every
maker is proud of the accurate
representation in cocoa food if you've
ever watched any animation movies you
probably notice that unless food is the
main focus of the story it probably
likes character and sometimes it even
doesn't look anything like the real deal
but the story is slightly different with
cocoa a lot of detail was also put into
actual animations to make sure the food
actually looks realistic this brings the
story to life and it's almost a shout
outs of Mexico's amazing cuisine it
makes sense right it's been known that
food is by far the hardest object to
animate and the details often give
animators a headache but what you didn't
know is how hard it was to getting the
right sheen on the turkey leg for Dante
to make sure they're doing it right
filmmakers referenced a lot of authentic
dishes and even made tamales together so
the team could get a feel of what the
food actually looks like well the team
definitely did something right if you're
going to highlight a culture and talk
about it you probably have to make sure
you pay attention to every detail to
make sure it's appreciated by the people
you're actually talking about we can't
even decide which food looks the best in
cocoa because they all look delicious
Ernesto dela Cruz speaking of detail
that went into this movie a lot of it
can actually be seen from owned esto de
la Cruz the musician that's completely
admired by Miguel Miguel was so inspired
by Ernesto he taught himself how to play
the guitar just by watching the videos
but what you didn't realize was just how
much detail went into Ernesto's
backstory the filmmakers created an
entire imaginary career which included a
timeline of his movies songs and albums
now that's pretty impressive to do for
someone that's not even the main
character of the story the producers
were really dedicated to creating
authentic characters arnesto was also
heavily influenced by real Mexican star
such as Pedro de bunda and jorge negrete
and actor benjamin bratt actually drew a
lot of inspiration from his father for
Ernesto's character they really wanted
to make sure that he wasn't just some
character with very little backstory
because who would believe that Miguel
would admire someone like that our
nestos character comes with so much
detail it almost seems like another
movie could be made just about him and
that's what makes Coco so awesome family
genes the character detail continues
when he noticed
little gem you probably missed in fact
we've rarely seen any other cartoon
actually pay so much attention to little
things but Coco seems to do this really
well normally cartoons only feature a
set of twins and we never get to learn
about their extended families and how
many twins there are because after all
we all know that having twins is genetic
so if they're common in your family
you're bound to have twins too
the Riviera family shares this detail as
Miguel has twin uncles as well as twin
cousins
Miguel's twin uncle's are tio Felipe and
tio Oscar and twin cousins are the
four-year-olds Vinny and Manny whether
this was intentional or not it's a
pretty cool thing to pay attention to
when you're trying to bring a story to
life a tumblr user hey hey
it's Jude you made an awesome Riviere
family tree where you can clearly see
the relations but we do wonder how far
this family tree actually goes because
we bet there are far more twins in the
Riviere family that we know of and let's
be honest Riviere twins are the best
cartoon twins ever with hardly any
competition from any other movies we're
telling you the detail in this movie is
amazing Finding Nemo guys we finally
found Nemo some of the characters seem
to have escaped the actual Finding Nemo
movie and they appeared in Cocoa after
receive the planet pizza truck Miguel
heads off to start his day and we see
him walk around town isn't it strange
how we get so many references and easter
eggs right at the beginning of the movie
it's a perfect way to make you want to
watch the entire thing anyways Miguel
ventures to the town center where you
can see a table with a bunch of toys on
it but they're not just any toys these
are the toys that characters can
purchase which is probably why they
resemble some of our favorite characters
ever can you find Nemo and Dory Nemo is
located behind the red giraffe on the
left side and Dory can be found in front
of the green dragon they're super small
but we promise you that you'll be able
to see them speaking of can you
recognize any other characters on the
table it's hard to tell if any of them
belong to any popular characters but we
know you have a far better eyesight for
these things than we do so if you do
catch something make sure to let us know
and that's it for this video don't
forget to subscribe to the things and
give this video a big thumbs up see you
time
[Music]